Mario backpacks and SLR mount
for your iPhone. It's episode 17 of LÜT.
Wear your glasses
and shades together in one piece while
browsing
portal necklaces, Aperture totes,
laptop stickers and on and on and on.
And here's a book that shows you how to
build weapons out of stuff you've got
around the office
or classroom. Now that you're officially
awesome, chew on some beef jerky
potato chips. And rather than buying
someone a card for
every occasion, buy a bunch of utility cards.
Each cards' word search contains more
than 100 wishes and sentiments,
so just circle the ones that apply to
that person on that day.
With all the time you save relax with a
drink in a doom glass
while wearing literary-themed t-shirts.
Moby Dick,
The Bell Jar, Tell-Tale Heart,
The Sun Also Rises and more.
Now look, cats love chasing laser
pointers, but why do all that difficult
hand moving when you could have the FroliCat BOLT
do it for you?
The Museum of Modern Art carries toast coasters
and a bubble necklace. Or make a bubble
necklace for free in the shower while
storing products on the shower squid.
Then clean your hands with some hand soap.
No, no, no.
Some hand soap. Once they're clean,
shove on some pickle
finger puppets while your pet finger paints
masterpieces with no mess thanks to ThinkGeek,
which also offers a bacon-scented air freshener
and chapstick.
I mean, SPAM flavored
lip glaze. Charge your phone in an emergency
with this solar powered USB charging
pack that gives you 8 extra hours of power
and teach your baby something new thanks to Tiffany
Ard. She designs X&Y chromosome earrings,
as well as this baby room picture
that teaches not ABC's, not 123's,
but prime numbers. From 2 ladybugs
to 41 pieces of bacon to 53 snails.
Before we run out of time, let's talk about time.
Telling it complexly and beautifully.
Tokyoflash designs amazing sci-fi
watches that you'll know how to read
while confusing strangers and attracting
hot alien ladies.
I leave you with some of NeatoShop's
I heart shirts.
And, not a free thing, but a free piece of
historical information -
what I like to call epic gifts in history.
In 1865, Seth Kinman
gave President Andrew Johnson a chair.
A chair made out of a bear.
Who exactly was Seth Kinman?
Well, he was a hunter who owned a bar and
once played fiddle for Abraham Lincoln.
You know, a fiddle that he made out of a mule
skull.
They're not yet available to buy online,
but in the meantime...
As always,
thanks for watching.
loom
that